in this episode our character makes it
through hates tower of flame and we
almost feel like we've been here before
so watch on and you'll discover the
origins behind this place and the beings
within it so back in majula we had two
paths open to us one was to the forest
of the fallen Giants which holds the
story of the war with the Giants that
happened a long time ago the other path
is down through the far gate down a
drain tunnel which leads out into Hades
Tower of flame aides tower of flame
we'll travel here first it is familiar
to us after all this city is the
remnants of a civilization that sank
into the sea long ago so long in fact
that nobody even remembers if hade is
the name of a kingdom or if it's the
name of a continent the kingdom was
built upon we see two structures that
remain one is the Cathedral which bears
resemblance to a kingdom long past and
the other is the Tower of flame itself a
lighthouse risen in stark defiance of
the ocean that leveled the rest of hade
so where are we why does this Cathedral
look so familiar I'm going to try and
answer some of these questions and I
should point out that we have two
characters one is just starting his
journey and the other is doing it all
over again in new game+
so it'll be interesting to see how
things change and the main reason I'm
going to be cutting between two
playthroughs is because it makes it more
interesting but also in mainly because
new game+ actually changes the game in
more ways than just making it more
difficult there's more enemies and with
more enemies comes more items and more
item descriptions and basically you get
a fuller experience in new game+ so one
of our characters has lit the bonfire
and the other one throws an ascetic into
it the first enemy we fight are these
Giants and these Giants are old very old
their equipment says that it's wielded
by a warrior from a time so ancient that
there exists no record of their
endeavors their equipment is crumbling
yet it tells us that sometimes just as a
thing falls to pieces it unleashes its
last flash of great power
there are reflection of the place they
exist within this city of hade with a
tower
and a cathedral which still stand and
still function in defiance even though
the city is crumbling
the second giant wields a mace and we
have a bit of trouble taking him out but
he dropped something particularly
interesting and this is our first hint
that hade is more than it seems
the second giant is guaranteed to drop
sublime bone dust this can be burned in
the medulla bonfire to make your Estus
flask more powerful but first let's
learn some more about it this dust is
charred ashen bones they say these are
the remains of a saint who cast himself
into the bonfire but we'll never know
for sure for soot and ashes tell no
story so who was the saint who cast
himself into the bonfire well who do you
think of first if you've played the
first game was it Lord Gwyn surely
someone who linked the fire in a
previous age it could be any of these
people and this is an example of the law
you build for yourself I can't tell you
what's right you come up with your own
story this brings me to one thing I want
to talk about with hade and he'll the
entire game in general drangleic
reflects Lord run in many ways the
journey you take is similar the souls
you find a similar some of the areas are
even similar for example we just talked
about the sublime bone dust and the
saint who cast himself into the flames
does that mean it's Lord Gwyn or solare
maybe but it could just as likely be
someone like them maybe another chosen
Undead who existed in an age before Lord
run and this one what I'm trying to say
is that not only does the spirit of the
first game live on it repeats itself and
there's a law reason for that and I'll
talk about it in later episodes but just
for now I think you should bear that in
mind so our hero makes it to the dragon
rider who blocks a path in hade we could
have run past these slow crumbling
Giants but that's what the developer
wants you to do this game wants you to
run through like you would in Dark Souls
and it wants you to miss these levers
that raise the platforms in the boss
room and these platforms make the boss
so much easier you can't fall off
anymore it's a level that wants to
punish you for running through and not
taking out the old
Giants but our character is patient and
the Dragon Rider is easier because of it
the Dragon Riders are faithful servants
of King vendrick they rode into battle
on worms which I suppose are a type of
Dragon this is an elite group and many
who trained to become a dragon rider a
torn apart by the Dragons they attempt
to command luckily this dragon rider is
alone and he's so much easier because of
it like every other heavily armoured
enemy in this zone it's much easier to
take him out with a crushing weapon and
luckily we have a mace his halberd is
easily dodged and it isn't much of a
threat to you if you stay really close
to him and avoid the blade and after the
dragon rider is vanquished we go
upstairs and light the bonfire we should
leave now
but there's still one place we need to
see the Cathedral before we go though we
see a human praying in this deserted
place and maybe her miracles will help
us with what's to come are you from
these parts my name is Lysia I have come
to spread the art of miracles a practice
of which I am a disciple
I'd heard awful rumors about this place
and I'm afraid they were all true the
King gone the earth ravaged sometimes I
fight the urge to pack up and go back
home
it is well
I must do this and being out here all
alone only makes this a more fitting
test of my fortitude I expected this
Cathedral to be bustling but there's
hardly a soul to be found here without
any goings on I'll have to move soon to
a place I could call them sorry
help the gullible by teaching the good
word this next fight gives us another
hint about the true nature of hate the
old Dragonslayer Ornstein appears before
us again this is one of those moments
that I honestly hope you experience
in-game without having it spoiled for
you and I'm sorry if I did that when you
see him it's a bit of a shock on stains
changed but he's also the same the
biggest difference is that he doesn't
have snow with him
I guess he died of diabetes or something
anyway so many questions are we fighting
the real Ornstein now or were we
fighting a false Ornstein in Lordran his
soul and item descriptions simply say
that this is a being reminiscent of the
Dragon Slayer you might have your own
theories and they're probably just as
valid as mine so to explain my theory on
Ornstein I finally have to explain my
entire theory behind aids tower of flame
so this area looks like an Orlando but I
don't think it's the anor londo of the
past nor do I even think that drangleic
is in the same geographical location as
Lord run the dev said that this game
takes place in a different land and I
choose to believe them for now AIDS
tower of flame has elements of Anor
Londo sure but I think that's because it
has people from anor londo within it we
know that many kingdoms have risen and
fallen since the events in Lordran in
the first game a couple of NPCs tell us
this information and we'll get to them
eventually but this explains why the
origins of Heydar lost in time and
here's why I think hate bears
resemblance to an Elan
as the flame was fading in Lordran many
of the gods in the first game started to
abandon the kingdom we know this from
the item descriptions and the most
noteworthy of these desertions was
Gwynn's daughter Guinevere and her
husband flan the god of flame I'll just
let that sink in for a moment it could
be that the Tower of flame is a homage
to flan the god of flame and it could be
that the architecture and the style of
this place is based off the design that
Guinevere brought with her when she
founded a new kingdom this design might
have been all she knew it also partly
explains why Ornstein is here since he
was assigned to the task of protecting
the princess of sunlight Guinevere so
who was the Ornstein we fought in the
first game well the Ornstein guarding
the illusion of a princess in Anor Londo
could also be an illusion constructed by
Gwendolyn although I don't really like
this theory much since he felt pretty
real when he was stabbing me with his
spear hundreds of times and yeah there's
just so many questions surrounding
Ornstein that I can't say much for
certain he no longer even uses lightning
to take you out which is interesting
we know that dragons are weak to
lightning yet he resides in a kingdom
where his allies actually ride dragons
I can't imagine he's too happy about
that but that assumes that ornstein is
still sane because he now uses dark
magic which makes us think of his
brother in arms
Artorius it seems like he has more
control over the abyss magic than
artorias did but has he become corrupted
by the dark like artorias was or has he
simply chosen to use it willingly since
lightning isn't useful to him anymore
one of the above could be true and I
could be missing something for now I'll
say something that doesn't have that
much counter evidence that the old
Dragon Slayer we fight here is a false
idol of hate and we'll leave it at that
this guy right here is tar gray who
oversees the blue sentinels transient
being this is no place for one such as
you begone you are not needed the blue
sentinels are a covenant that hunts down
the guilty once we find a token of
fidelity which is an item you get for
invading we become a
to join his covenant the Sentinels of
blue invade the guilty with the cracked
blue eye orbs and in the future we're
going to try and do this
the Sentinels believe in an absolute
good and an absolute evil tar gray comes
across as condescending but he simply
has this unwavering faith in his own
actions and his covenant if you don't
meet the requirements you don't get an
audience with him no matter how hard I
tried with this video I can't cover all
the valid speculation myself so I'm
going to pass the torch on to you guys
debate in the comments section and maybe
link this video on some forums and
discuss the same questions I had here
about AIDS tower of flame because I
can't possibly give you all the answers
and I would love to see you come up with
your own but this is my story and I hope
you enjoyed it I've removed unskipable
adds mid-roll ads and post-roll ads from
this video and that's because of the
400-plus people who kindled this channel
these people are making my videos better
for everybody and that's awesome
click the bonfire to find out more in
the next episode of story mode we'll
focus on the forest of the Fallen Giants
we discussed king vendrick's war with
the Giants and a curious hidden artifact
found in majula I'll see you next time